hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the semi-finals of the
speed chess championship on chess.com
yeah it's the semi-finals uh as as i've
already mentioned
hikaru nakamura versus the wesley so and
it will be a nice opportunity for hikaru
to get back at wesley for
losing to him in the skilling open that
took place uh
uh a month ago so without further ado
let's check it out and
this is a game from the bullet portion
for those of you who don't know uh the
speed change
chess championship uh is uh played in
three time four
formats first it's uh uh blitz five plus
one
then uh more blitz three plus one and
this is from the bullet section one plus
one so not
the insane bullet one plus zero seconds
increment but actually every time you
make a move you get a one second
increment
and for super grand master such as
hikaru and wesley
that's pretty much infinite time uh so
uh without further ado
let's check it out and we're gonna
discuss on uh the
the results of the match afterwards uh
so
let's see what happens hikaru with the
white pieces opens with
e4 uh we have e5 by wesley
uh sorry about that and knight to f3 by
hikaru now we have knight to c6
bishop to b5 the rule lopez is on the
board and
knight to f6 wesley goes uh for the
berlin defense and i know what you're
thinking who
who plays the berlin in a bullet game uh
but that's uh what uh top level chess
is like so d3 and now bishop to c5
getting that bishop into the game c3 now
grabbing the center and the castles by
black and here
there are a lot of possible moves like
castles bishop to g5
all very popular but the move nakamura
played as uh has only been played once
uh he plays queen to e2
and it was played in uh 2012 in a game
uh between 18 vacro
and maze which was actually won by black
but we're going to get back to that
so d6 preparing to develop the light
square bishop and bishop to g5 pinning
the knight
wesley kicks away the bishop h6 bishop
to h4 and now g5
pushing the bishop further back and now
knight to h5 preparing to shift that
knight over to f4 square
and at that point the black will either
have a monster knight on f4
or nakamura will have to give up the
dark square bishop so here at knight bd2
nakamura says all right as uh it doesn't
seem to be all this pleasant on the king
side we're
to castle queenside this game and here
we have queen to f6 by wesley in the
game that i mentioned before
bakro versus maze in 2012 g4 was played
but queen to f6
is now a new move so uh already as of
movie 11 we have a completely new game
sorry as a move 10.
uh we have h3 uh taking uh
control of g4 also not allowing bishop
to g4 and here
knight to e7 the knight can now come at
g6 then to f4 now it's going to be it's
going to be
uh well a lot of options for this knight
so knight to h2 nakamura prepares to
shift the knight to g4 to attack the
queen in the h6 pawn
and knights to f4 now as planned
attacking the queen attacking the
g2 pawn if the queen moves uh the the g2
pawn falls so here
nakamura decides to eliminate the knight
with bishop captures on f4 g
captures g captures and now finally
nakamura goes for a queen side castle
and it's a very uh very interesting idea
there's
black's king side is now open so
nakamura of course wants to open up the
king side and
start attacking it but his king is also
not as
all that safe on the queen side and here
it's very instructive
how wesley even in a bullet game takes
advantage of this and it's all due to
this bishop being placed on b5 so here
uh he starts uh his pawn storm on the
queen side by taking advantage of this
bishop's position so here a6
doesn't matter if the bishop goes to a4
or c4 your next movie is the same so
here wesley played bishop c4
and now b5 further chasing the bishop
down
bishop b3 and now b4 so wesley was able
to get all of these moves in
because the bishop was on b5 and that's
a very instructive thing to do
as you can see if you if you know such
things you will spot it instantly even
in a bullet game
so b4 and now knight the g4 the queen is
under attack so here
uh you just either move the queen or or
capture the knight but of course uh
wesley doesn't want to give nakamura the
open h
file uh to be used for the rook so here
queen back to g7
and here nakamura trade c captures
bishop captures and now
knight sorry knight to f3 uh we have
a5 wesley now of course wants to push a4
uh kick away that bishop from there and
now
g3 here nakamura wants to open up the g
file put a rook on the g
file and then take advantage of wesley's
queen and king being on the same
g file so here a4 chasing the bishop
back bishop to c4
and now knight to g6 uh
sort of giving another another defender
to the to the queen and king but now
rook h the g1 before capturing nakamura
places a rook on the g
file now only now bishop captures on g4
h captures and now a3 so now capturing
uh isn't all that impressive because
they're still the
the the g file has two pawns on it
and here we have g5 uh interestingly b3
is also a possibility
uh because it doesn't allow black to
break through here but nakamura says
this is not a problem so instead he just
continues the attack with the g5
and okay we have c6 here and the c6 is
also
very interesting because if you just go
for captures king b1
there's no real way to take advantage of
this you don't have any tricks like rook
captures here bringing the other rook
into the game because the bishop
covers the a2 square so your options are
very very limited here
so here instead after g5 we have c6 by
wesley
now he wants to take advantage if he
could somehow bust open this center and
get rid of this pawn
then maybe this queen could do some uh
damage along this diagonal so here
king to b1 uh a nice prophylactic move
by hikaru not allowing this to ever
ever come with tempo so rook to a5
here wesley makes room for the other
rook to come
join this rook on the a file but also uh
gets uh
more pressure on the d5 square as he is
preparing d5
so g captures on f4 now grabbing that
pawn and now
d5 as planned we have g captures on h6
queen captures and now e captures on d5
also very interesting was f5 as the
knight cannot move and here
it would be incredibly difficult for for
black to defend but i must remind
everyone
this is one plus one bullet so queen
kept captures on h6
we have e captures on d5 and now c
captures on d5 the bishop finally has to
move
bishop to b3 and then now comes queen
captures on
f4 and it seems like uh wesley is out of
the woods and
maybe preparing a nice attack of its of
of his own
but there is a problem uh feel free to
pause the video
and win this game for hikar while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
ah okay i just received an excellent
message
so i will mention what the message is
about after uh
we check out the position so uh for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on spotting this
very nifty tactic and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
it's knight captures on e5 of course the
knight cannot be captured because if you
capture just queen
captures and the knight is pinned you
will not be able to capture back the
queen
so after this queen captures on f4 we
have knight captures on
e5 like we said and now king to g7 by
wesley
but now hikaru just ends the game with
the very very
uh well straightforward rook to g4
and now uh wesley doesn't really have a
move here the queen is under attack the
queen has to move and the bishop on b4
will hang
because after you move it you can even
trade once on g6 captures captures and
then you're gonna capture on b4
and you're just up a piece with black uh
not having anything to show for it and
it's just gonna be a a very quick death
for black
with you know any moves pretty much uh
so yeah
uh a great victory for hikaru and it was
a really tight match
as they mentioned on chess.com it was uh
the closest match so far
now i will even put a link in the
description below it will be a link to
peter dodger's article on chess.com with
a bit more info on the match so do check
that out as well
because it was really really close
hikaru won the first match by a one
point margin so the five plus one
segment was won by hikaru
then wesley won the three plus one
segment uh also by a one point margin
and then hikaru was victorious in the
bullet section again with a one point
margin so it was a really really a tough
fight
and uh uh you know really really crazy
because hikaru started winning i think
he car won like three bullet games
with wesley winning the zero and then
wesley started coming back uh
and i think he also won three hikaru in
the end won four
uh so maybe you know if wesley had more
time to get used to the bullet uh maybe
maybe
he did do better but as hikaru said in
an interview after the match uh
in the quote above the board in many
ways he was the better player of the
match
uh but hikaru is the one that was
victorious so hikaru got his revenge
for being kicked out of skilling open uh
by wesley so and we will not see
a wesley magnus a rematch in the finals
or
rather we might not even see magnus in
the finals we'll see what happens
because hikaru is the first finalist of
the speed cheers championship here is
uh some graphics from chess.com so you
can see hikaru defeated everyone
he uh reached the the finals uh and then
uh we still have to wait for the clash
of magnus skulls and versus maxine
vachelagrav that will be on friday
to see who will join hikaru in the
finals
so that's uh pretty much it uh for the
for the speeches championship we're go
i'm probably gonna show one more game uh
from this clash as
the the games do seem to be very
interesting if you if you have your own
favorite
also do use hashtag suggestion and i
will
definitely check it out uh so that's
regarding this game
and now uh the the message i uh that
was uh telling you about uh it's
actually regarding
our chess manga so uh adam genesis you
know him
uh by his many many great feats but also
he's one of the artists uh
in our chess manga and he made a video
of chapter one so if you still haven't
checked it out or if you have and uh
just want to see
a video preview of it it's really really
awesome because he does
all the voices by himself so the the
voice of the narrator the voice of
grandpa
and the voice of zed uh and even the
robot
little fritz are done by him so i will
put
that in the description below as well it
will be the first thing you'll see
so do check it out it's uh it's quite uh
a nice preview of of chapter one and if
you also have a
uh maybe uh well some some free time and
also an idea if you want to try and make
your own
also do share it with me i'm gonna share
it with everyone as uh
this was very enjoyable for me so do
check it out first link in the
description below
so yeah uh that's uh the game ended the
message so i do hope you enjoyed that
i would like to thank giuseppe russo ron
crawford matt lambert
uh austin del rio and nicolas contact
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga of course uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank y'all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day